sur le président ma question s'est
adressé à madame la première ministre
dans le prolongement de la question
posée par ma collègue françoise gatel
madame la première ministre vous avez à
plusieurs reprises dans cette enceinte
jeudi dernier notamment lors de votre
discours de politique générale à fermer
votre respect pour le sénat et votre
volonté de vous inspirer à l'avenir de
ces travaux en voici une occasion à
travers un sujet majeur qui préoccupe
aujourd'hui les maires celui de
l'objectif du zéro artificialisation net
qu'on va donc appelé âmes et je peux
vous dire après avoir fait une trentaine
de déplacement dans un pays que les élus
sont en ébullition sur ce sujet que
distille que le than sur metropolis
notre pays une fois de plus que unis
notre ruralité une fois de plus
également que distille ils disent que
l'êta abandonne tout le monde puisqu'il
n'y a aucune ingénierie mise à la
disposition de nos élus pour réussir cet
objectif est que reproche-t-il il
reproche au pouvoir réglementaire que
vous représentez vous incarnez de
revenir sur la loi et c'est quand même
assez grave quand on pense à la
hiérarchie des normes pas encore
prononcé ces mots que le pouvoir
réglementaire retranche à la loi votée
que disait cette loi votée ici que
lausanne n'étiez pas contre mais par
contre nous et tirs ont opposé à la
méthode descendante à ce centralisme
régional punitif que qui était proposée
alors nous avons fait voter une
territorialisation de l'objectif par
exemple nous avons au lieu d'être adepte
et le plus souple possible nous avons
demandé à ce qu'on prenne en compte les
trajectoires des élus qui sont dans la
sobriété foncière depuis longtemps nous
avons demandé de faire confiance aux
élus est tout simplement à travers les
scot qui fait ce vous faites qui puisse
vous faire des propositions personne ne
comprend pourquoi c'est d'écrire aux
tranches à la loi alors c'est décret est
dévitalisé puisque vous compter à
présent changer de méthode et prendre en
compte les inquiétudes de nous tous et
des élus en particulier
comptez vous réellement réexaminer ces
décrets et revenir réellement sur la
volonté exprimée par le parlement